what's that belief nation I am about to
embark on a really scary journey I'm
feeling anxious about it I'm feeling
nervous about it and generally that's a
good thing when you're feeling anxious
and nervous and you need to someone your
courage it means you're on the right
path I've decided to blow up I've
decided that I want to go from my 1.7
million subscribers to 10 million I've
decided that I want to be a household
name I've decided that my mission is
important enough that it needs to reach
people and as long as I continue to go
at this pace it's gonna take me forever
to get to where I want to go and that's
not acceptable anymore
I have been playing small by my own
standards I think when other people look
what I'm doing they say wow you're doing
so much great stuff you're taking such
big risks and for me I don't feel like
they're big risks for me I feel like I'm
playing inside my comfort zone not even
at the edge you're beyond my comfort
zone and as a result the pace of growth
isn't what it should be
I've been afraid of disappointing people
it's my number one fear of disappointing
people of letting people down I hate it
and so as a result I don't go off and
take big risks because I'm worried about
letting somebody down and I need to get
over that and I need to be able to make
content fearless leap so that I can get
to where I need to go and the impact
that people need to impact and so I'm
certain new series to document this
journey it took me I don't know nine
years to get the 1 million subscribers
and then I got to 1.7 this year but from
1 million T in the last year to 1.7
y'know this year if I keep growing at
that pace it's just gonna take me way
too long to get the 10 million and so
you can grow through these minor
increments which I've been doing taking
the slow steady calculated approach and
getting consistent growth in your
business and I've been doing that for
years and making three videos a day for
years and I'll keep doing that and it's
a great way to grow and sometimes when
you're ready for quantum leap forward
you just got to take life by the horns
and go after it and it means taking
bolder bets and it means getting out of
your own way and it means doing
something that you're gonna be scared to
do and I'm ready to do that I'm ready to
be willing to risk disappointing people
letting people down facing my fears and
hopefully in this new sea
I'm gonna be created on my channel my
climb to 10 million it also inspires you
to go off and chase that big dream in
that big goal of yours so on the climb
to 10 million I'm breaking it down into
four parts which will be regular series
on this channel part 1 will be bolder
bets I'm gonna introduce you to my agent
Steve that I've been working with for a
number of years and in this series he's
gonna be helping me get on bigger stages
how do we get the oven chemical brand
known more how do we get me inside of
the organization's and on the platforms
that will help spread the message
further in places I've never been to
before that will stretch my comfort zone
and push me to be better I've made a
list called the 22 crew which are 22
people who I would love to have on my
channel 1 because most of them haven't
ever done an entrepreneurial type of
interview and I think the perspective
would be really valuable and 2 because
it will help my channel and it will help
gain more reach and exposure for what
I'm doing some of these names you've
seen before most of them though you
haven't seen a great interview around
entrepreneurship on and I think it'll be
great not just for my channel to help
blow it up but also for the community to
get these people's perspectives on where
the world is heading and how
entrepreneurs can be a big part of that
solution
these are 22 of some of the hardest
people to reach in the world though and
so it's gonna take a lot of effort a lot
of failure a lot of rejection to get
them on board my channel but that's
gonna be part of my mission to bring
them on and chase them down now I'm
gonna take you on that journey of me
trying to get them on and deal with all
the rejection that comes along with it
so the 22 crew are Arnold Schwarzenegger
Kanye West Jordan Peterson Will Smith
the rock Jack mod Gary Vee Priyanka
Chopra Oprah Winfrey Michelle Obama Bill
Gates Warren Buffett Tony Robbins jay-z
Beyonce Jeff Bezos Elon Musk Michael
Jordan JK Rowling the Dalai Lama Mark
Zuckerberg and Taylor Swift so if any of
you guys know those people personally
let me know I'd love an introduction but
otherwise you get to watch me and my
agent chase them down to bring some
value to you on my channel the second
part I call Evan therapy where I'm gonna
be working with a trained psychologist
one on one every month to work through
whatever issues I'm facing like why am i
afraid of disappointing people and how
do I get over that and are
any techniques that can speed up my
process so it's not this slow
incremental gain and hopefully in
uncovering whatever is is inside me that
is blocking me from getting to the next
level it also inspires you to go off and
do the same every major breakthrough
that I found in my life for business has
come from busting through a limiting
personal belief when I was 19 I had my
software company I was afraid I was too
young people wouldn't take me seriously
I was afraid that science was my worst
subject and I was selling scientific
software to people who had multiple
phd's in it and it wasn't till I
realized that they don't care what my
background is as long as I can bring
them value then that started shifting my
business forward and so it's great to
have the strategies of what to actually
do but all the strategies in the world
won't work if you have a story that
you're telling yourself that is holding
you back and so a big part of it is I
don't know what I don't know and I don't
know what all my stories are that are
holding me back so I know I don't like
to supporting people I know I need to be
able to overcome that I know I need to
summon the courage to do it and
hopefully by spending the time with a
psychologist every month and working
through my issues it'll help me get to
the next level a lot faster segment 3 I
call star power and that's where I'm
partnering up with Hank Norman who is a
media mogul he's also at the agency that
I'm with and he is an expert in turning
people into stars he's worked with my
Robbins and Grant Cardone and Steve
Harvey and a whole bunch of other people
are turning them into stars and so
that's what I need to do I need I need
to become a star I need to get my name
out there I need to spread my message
further and spread positivity and spread
hope and spread belief and I need I need
to get better to do that and so in this
segment we're gonna be looking at my
content he's gonna tear me apart he's
gonna say all the reasons why I suck and
where I need to get it better how I can
improve as a speaker how I can improve
on camera how I can improve with my
content how I can improve when coaching
people all of it and we're gonna be
breaking down my clips and learning how
to get known how to improve how to get
better tearing me down hopefully
building up a brand new evidence and
then segment four is if I call YouTube
masters we're going to be bringing on
people who
I respect in the YouTube world for
different reasons and we're gonna be
tearing down my youtube channel and
fixing my thumbnails and fixing my
titles and fixing my content and fixing
my audience retention and fixing my
subscribers and fixing everything to get
me growing at a faster clip than what
I'm at now it all comes down to I want
to play a bigger game I'm ready to play
a bigger game I don't want to just keep
getting the incremental growth but I
want to take a quantum leap forward and
I need to get out of my own way to do it
and instead of again doing these little
bits by bits so improvements I'm asking
for help
I'm talking to people who I respect and
look up to in different fields who are
gonna push me who are gonna break me
down who are going to rebuild me who are
gonna support me hopefully along my
journey again I hope that in my
breakdown and rebuilding to go play a
bigger game it also inspires you to have
the courage and confidence to go off and
play a bigger game for yourself so it's
a new series starting next week I hope
you'll join me on this journey we're
calling it my climb to 10 million I love
to hear your quick feedback thoughts
leave it down in the comments below
looking forward to having you on this
journey with me continue to believe and
I'll see you soon